AI is going to be
it's a more efficient way to do fraud
yeah that's what it amounts to but that
doesn't mean that the bank is going to
not be responsible for your ten thousand
dollars that was in your account before
some AI aided hacker cleans your account
out it just becomes one more way fraud
could exactly more it's more efficient
for everyone uh to you know to do
content to create fraud to violate
copyrights or trademarks or steal images
and so you know if you want to be
crooked it's a more efficient way to be
crooked that's the downside of this
technology it's uh highly Innovative and
highly efficient oh my God it's amazing
but also it's got such a powerful thing
for good kind of feels like when the
internet was on the horizon we all went
this is scary but also amazing I think
we're just gonna all adapt